so i've got this crazy discontinuous
function here which we'll call f of x
and my goal is to try to draw its
derivative right over here so what i'm
going to need to think about is the
slope of the tangent line or the slope
at each point in this curve and then try
my best to draw that slope so let's
let's try to tackle it
so right over here
right over here at this point the slope
is positive and actually it's a good bit
it's a good bit positive and then as we
get larger and larger x's the slope is
still positive but it's less positive
it's less positive and all the way up to
this point right over here where it
becomes where it becomes zero
so let's see how i could draw that over
here so over here we know that the slope
must be equal to zero right over here
remember over here i'm going to try to
draw y is equal to
f prime
f prime of x and i'm going to assume
that this is this is some type of a
parabola and you'll learn shortly why i
had to make that assumption but let's
say
that so let's see here the slope is
quite positive so let's say the slope is
right over here and then it gets less
and less and less positive and i'll
assume it does it in a linear fashion
that's why i had to assume that it's
some type of a parabola so it gets less
and less and less positive notice here
the slope here for example the slope is
still positive
and so when you look at the derivative
the slope is still a positive value but
as we get larger and larger x's up to
this point the slope is getting less and
less positive all the way to zero and
then the slope is getting more and more
negative and at this point it seems like
the slope is just as negative as it was
positive there so this point right over
here the slope is just as negative
just as negative as it was positive
right over there so it seems like this
would be a reasonable
a reasonable view of the slope
of the slope of the tangent line over
this interval
now let's think about as we get to this
point here the slope seems constant our
slope is a constant positive value so
once again
our slope here is a constant positive
line let me be careful here because at
this point our slope won't really be
defined because our slope you could draw
a multiple you could draw multiple
tangent lines at this little point this
little pointy point so let me just draw
a circle
let me draw a circle right over there
but then as we get right over here the
slope the slope seems to be
the slope seems to be positive so let's
draw that the slope seems to be positive
and although it's not as positive as it
was there so the slope
the slope looks like it is i'll make it
i'll just i'm just trying to eyeball it
so the slope is a constant positive this
entire time we have a line with the
constant positive slope so it might look
something
something like this and let me make make
it clear what interval
let me make it clear what interval i am
talking about i want these things to
match up
so let me
do my best so this
this matches up
this matches up to that this matches up
over here and we just said we have a
constant positive slope
so let's say it looks something
it looks something like that over this
interval and then we look at this point
right over here so right at this point
our slope is going to be undefined
there's no way that you could find the
slope over or this point of
discontinuity but then when we go over
here even though the value of our
function has gone down we still have a
constant positive slope in fact the
slope of this line looks identical to
the slope of this line let me do that in
a different color
the slope of this line looks identical
so we're going to continue at that same
slope it was undefined at that point but
we're going to continue at that same
slope
slope and once again it's undefined here
at this point of discontinuity
so the slope will look something like
that
and then we go up here the value of the
function goes up but now the function is
flat so the slope over that interval is
0. the slope over this interval
right over here is zero so we could
say the slope over that interval let me
make it clear what interval i'm talking
about
the slope over this interval
is zero
and then finally in this last section in
this last section the slope let me do
this in orange in this last section the
slope becomes negative but it's a
constant negative it's a constant
negative and it seems actually a little
bit more negative than these were
positive so i would draw it i would draw
it
right
over there so it's a weird looking
function but the whole point of this
video is to give you an intuition for
thinking about what the slope or of this
function might look at it at any point
and by doing so we have essentially
drawn the derivative over that interval